it's like this
you said this to me on christmas and i
was dying
by the way this is the perfect video
except can you point out with the one
thing about this video i don't like
um well they're not socially distancing
and they're not wearing masks
my problem is the woman that keeps
narrating it
well they film it that's everything it's
a woman royce they'd never film
eating [ __ ] cheese noodles
we've we've all we have
all met somebody like this dude
you know what's crazy no it's crazy i'm
gonna walk to you i'm gonna walk right
to my house for you bro
oh god i'm not trying to disrespect you
i'm gonna say all day all every day are
you kidding me
where are you from where are you from
where the [ __ ] you from you from here
get the [ __ ] out of you a clown oh god
you're a clown
you're from here you're a clown
the thing is like he's gotta be he even
knew it he
he even knew it and he said what are you
gonna
smack me with that yeah i think that's
his plan
i i think he
[Music]
if i had to guess this guy is probably
doing coke or some kind of
upper and he probably literally just
took it like
he probably took it and then was like
damn i'm out of cigarettes and like had
to go get cigarettes
so he's it's hitting him right now and
he's just like i'm ready to fight
i'm ready to do something and he just he
won't let this
and by the way this is the perfect
situation of like where
because like you see videos all the time
this [ __ ] and like i don't condone
hitting people i really don't for no
reason right
but this is a dude this is a man just
begging
begging to get [ __ ] cracked in his
head like he's begging for it
it's like you ever see like your stories
of somebody that got killed
and then you like learn about the guy
that got murdered and you go oh this was
a man who lived every day of his life
begging for someone to [ __ ] kill him
and this is like this is that guy
he's begging for somebody to [ __ ]
kill him
[Music]
come on
oh man by the way the fumble does hurt
yeah it does hurt a little bit it does
hurt as cool it does if he would have
been
cooler if he didn't drop it he shouldn't
have done the little toss move yeah but
yeah that was
by the way i've never i've never seen
a sealed can explode like that like that
is
one of the most that's yeah that was do
you know how hard that is to do
that's that's a very hard thing to
accomplish just making a can explode
like that that's [ __ ]
oof can we see that we see it in slow-mo
can we slow it down a little bit i gotta
see this
hey guys
wow it's so fast even in slow-mo
it's so fast even in slow-mo i'm gonna
try to go a little bit slower if i can't
wow dude here we go
oh my god even at a quarter speed oh
[ __ ] that's as slow as you could go
that's the slowest you can do it's a
quarter speed and he's
wow he thought i felt that
[Music]
you ever seen a twisted t come about
like that no i gotta i do have
one bone of contention with this video
is that they start to struggle and he
keeps saying you're gonna call me the n
word
you know and he's saying it with the
hard er and he keeps saying end with the
hard er now
to be fair this man did not call you the
n-word
just to try to imply that this white man
clearly
has an n-word pass i could tell you just
watching this guy i'm sure he doesn't
i'm sure he lives the life
to a certain extent i'm sure he lives
like so
uh saying what's up
is not the same as being online and
being like
you know what i mean like to some guy
that that you know what i mean i don't
understand when you say
like i know you're not supposed to hit
people for words but there's also
an unspoken understanding that if you
called it the black guy the n word
you probably agree so so so this is i've
watched this video several times
like you have to right here's my take
away from it right well okay hold on
let's finish playing this because
we i'm sure everyone's seen it but just
in case yeah let's play the last one
you did get right up yeah you got yours
buddy
shut up this part of the fight's really
[ __ ]
fun
okay okay okay by the way okay
by the way i like okay i love the okay
but he's trying to be like
like it's cool you know what i mean like
he's trying to be
cool like okay yeah yeah okay
like he's still playing it off like you
wait you wait to like yo man when i get
out of this like he still has that
attitude in his voice
now first off he doesn't he he doesn't
look when you see him
he looks more like arab than he does
black
but whatever my my thing is my takeaway
of this video is a little bit different
right
my thing is is that i don't think he
look i i don't think he hit this guy
because he called them
right i really i don't i don't think so
okay
um i think that he hit this guy because
eve look this guy we agree even if this
guy wasn't calling him the
the with an a even if he wasn't saying
that
this guy deserved to be hit in this
situation right
like this guy wasn't hit because he said
the n-word
this guy was hit because he was being an
annoying piece of [ __ ] that kept blowing
up it kept going up
and he finally got a receipt for it you
know because this guy at the beginning
was like just wanted him to leave you
could tell he's not saying anything
the black guy's not doing anything he's
standing there i think after he hit him
with the can right
and after he he realized well this is
assault
however if i claim that it's race-based
more people are going to be on my side
he's hiding behind it
that's that's that's what i'm seeing
right i'm thinking he's using it as a
because if this was two white dudes
right and they were just arguing
and one guy cracked the other guy you
couldn't use the n-bomb as a shield
i believe that he's using the n-bomb
because now the entire internet's like
oh you deserved it because you called
them the n-word
you know it wasn't just two people
fighting so i that's that's my takeaway
and of course
i'm not on this guy's head right so i
don't know what the reasoning is
but i do believe i do believe that
that's what happened in this video
what about a show like
agents of shield right but
uh they fly around in a private jet
and hunt down people that say the n-word
i like that
same cast and everything um no you're
right though and uh
and look the whole using the
he called me the n-word as a shield
thing it's definitely overused i think a
bit
and it usually is used to justify shitty
behavior um
the i think the biggest the biggest
offender would be new jack
have you ever seen new jack interviews
or
any anything with new jack talking about
um things he's done that were terrible
oh he
coached it in racism always yeah yeah
yeah like any anything that there was
really no proof
of like he'll be like oh he called me to
n word and you're like
okay do you have any proof of that and
he never seems to have any proof of it
and um it's just any time you go new
jack why did you set that guy on fire
man backstage he was calling me n word
this n word that and you're like
okay was he really though like let's
let's
and then uh teddy long is another guy
that always does that like every story
with teddy longest he called me to n
word and you're like well
you know is there any proof yeah well so
so
this one this one's one of those where
i'm like ah
look is anyone upset this guy got
[ __ ] hit i don't think so right no
it's pretty good like
it's i think it's one of those things
where he
this is a situation where some people go
he was asking for it but in this case
he literally asked to get hit in the
head with it he said go ahead
hit me and he got hit
yeah not often you get your wishes
granted but the twisted t
[ __ ] genie over here grants one wish
and he [ __ ] granted it right over his
stupid face
now i have a question this is more of a
practical question but did he have to
pay for two
twisted tees
hold on is it cashier black cashier's
black no
probably didn't charge him give it to
him on the house that's my guess
but no cause i mean look i get that i
say you dropped it i'm going off
i'll put it down as breakage
[Laughter]
yeah like it's all good man it's fine i
got you dog don't worry about it yeah
don't worry we straight
nah he opens his wallet and he pays for
it yeah
but i'm thinking cowboy movies right i
think in cowboys
cowboy movies where it's like whiskey's
on me because you took the bad guy out
of course whiskey's on me like that's
what happened some horror and a [ __ ]
some corset comes over like an old-timey
corset
and [ __ ] you yes it's great not a lot
of round on you
good westworld reference that was very
good oh he's [ __ ]
beat but have you seen the pictures of
him afterwards like his two black eyes
like he's
[ __ ] up this guy's [ __ ] up
um if uh but you know the thing is it's
like
again man i'm not i i i will agree with
you what you said earlier like i'm not a
dude who's like you should be hitting
people over words right
but it that being said
legality and human nature in many ways
aren't
oh don't don't always call it they're
not in line
and if somebody keeps getting in your
face and if companies somebody keep like
again i know there's probably a lot of
people like what started it
i don't know what started it but this
guy was the clearer the white guy was
the aggressor
the arizona iced tea ended it i'll tell
you that that's it
not even dude it was a twisted tea
that's it more expensive those are the
alcohol ones
okay those are the expensive ones man
it popped right in his [ __ ] head